Tim Cook has done it again and while
some people are out here saying the
Apple silicon has been defeated sorry
Alex apple is out here dominating
kicking butt and taking names with a lot
of these world's best headlines so with
that said should you upgrade to a new M3
based Mac well in this video I will
answer that question now a lot of people
thought we're not going to get an event
this year but here we have it and there
were three to four Shockers at this
announcement now of course we got the
new 3 nanometer M3 base chips the
world's first 3 nanometer in a computer
and the iPhone just got 3 nanometer what
about a month ago and now it is in a Mac
which is awesome but with that Apple
announced the 14in MacBook Pro with M3
and that was one of the Shockers
previously we had the 13in MacBook Pro
which was a super old design that still
had that touch bar and it seems like
apple finally replaced it and instead of
just updating it slightly they just gave
it the 14in design with mag safe with
the HDMI and the SD card and the
Beautiful display that is not limited in
any way you still have all the high
brightness the refresh rates that is
amazing now you guys know that we had to
order a bunch of these and this was one
expensive event and we are going to be
covering the M3 the M3 Pro and the M3
Max doing a bunch of comparisons and
with that viim is working on a buyer's
guide to help you choose if you want to
order one right now so make sure you
guys have notifications enabled and for
the longer term people seeing what kind
of a difference you get if you spend way
more money and the first thing I want to
say is if you been waiting to buy a
budget MacBook the new M3 at that base
$1,600 price in that shell is going to
be a killer value now we will compare it
to an M2 Pro for two grand that I know
you'll be able to buy discounted at
similar price so make sure you guys are
subscribed now for those of you guys
that are buying higher-end models this
is where it gets tricky Apple started
out showing off their new dynamic
caching for graphics and this is a new
technology that nobody's really talked
about allowing your graphics card to
optimally use its memory so none of it
is wasted in downtime for GPU cycling of
course we're going to be testing that
out and seeing how it impacts real world
performance but that definitely is
interesting and then with that raate
tracing finally and raate tracing is not
only going to be for gaming like they
showed off along with the whole new mesh
shading as well but for rendering and
video editing tasks for example when
we've done comparisons against Windows
laptops MacBooks really really suffered
when you're doing 3D rendering and
Nvidia laptops would smoke them but now
that we have Hardware rate tracing this
is going to change that and I'm so
excited to check it out my concern with
these new M2 Pros is that they are
actually downgraded in some ways now at
the base configuration we have 18 gigs
of RAM which is great but one thing that
we discovered is that as far as the RAM
chips that are built into the machines
the 18 gigs now comes with three RAM
chips instead of four and that actually
lowers the bandwidth compared to the M1
Pro and the M2 Pro and that kind of
sucks we don't know what that's going to
do with real world performance and when
Apple talked about the M3 Pros
performance
they really compared it to the M1 Pro
which was kind of weird and they
mentioned multiple times about how much
faster things are compared to Intel uh
instead of to the M2 Pro and that just
makes things a little bit weird the M3
Pro is 40% faster than the M1 Pro and
now we have Hardware av1 decoding which
is great for streaming 8K content so
that is great and and we have 600 nits
of brightness for the display now
compared to 500 So 20% more but in the
real world it's not that noticeable it's
more for matching up to a studio display
but overall based on my impression of
the M3 Pro I was not that excited so if
you're looking to upgrade to that one I
would kind of wait and hold off for the
real world test now when we switch to
the M3 Max that is where things get very
very interesting you are now able to
spec it up all the way to 128 gigs of
memory and that is a crazy amount for a
laptop and I don't think most people
should spend that much money but as far
as performance we now have a 16 core CPU
so that's extra performance cores for
more that will make a much bigger
difference than before where the CPU was
basically the same as the M2 Pro and
without 40 Graphics cores and 48 gigs of
RAM but the price tag did go up if you
want that configuration the unbin
version to
$4,000 now on top of that I think the
second biggest shocker was the new space
black color this is what got us here
excited the most instead of this actual
performance that they talked about and
it's finally nice to see a black color
but not only that the an aniz new
process that's going to minimize
fingerprints and you can even see that
in the video the texture that is on it
cuz most black laptops well they get
really ugly really fast and with that
the performance is much bigger in terms
of the previous generations we saw 50%
faster than the M2 Max they actually
said that out loud and then 80% faster
than the M1 Max so that is almost a
doubling of performance which is much
better and then you include the other
improvements and that could be really
nice in the real world and of course
Apple talked about efficiency with this
new series of chips and the performance
cores are better and the neural engine
is updated basically the same one from
the a17 pro processor so if you're
interested in an M3 Max Base laptop that
is where I could say yes it will be
worth upgrading we don't have to do a
lot more digging to figure that out now
of course they also released the updated
24in iMac they spent quite a bit of time
on this and it is very similar overall
but now it has the M3 chip so they
completely skipped over the M2 Chip
giving it the M3 and that made a
doubling of performance going from the
M1 to the m uh 3 design now I do wish
they give us a 27 in even if everything
was the same just a larger size but they
didn't so let me know if you are
interested in one of those iMacs so
overall this event was very interesting
they definitely changed up how they did
things and they spent a lot of time
focusing on this much faster than an
Intel based Mac and if you have an Intel
based MacBook you're going to see a huge
difference statements like that and also
the whole world's best statements which
they were very very strong in their um
kind of the quotes or kind of the
statements that they made so that was
very unique and it was only a 30 minute
event probably the quickest Apple event
that we have ever seen so that was also
um kind of a little bit weird and then
the last thing that really shocked me
was the ending where they showed off
that this was shot on an iPhone and
edited on a Mac and the footage looked
amazing so the new iPhone with the new
Pro res in log mode was able to do a
really great job on this video shoot so
you guys let me know are you going to be
upgrading and do you think it's worth it
and make sure you guys are subscribed
for our full series of videos the buyer
guide tomorrow also what everything that
Apple didn't tell you which is actually
stacking up right now we're making a
list of different things I didn't
mention um click that Circle above to
subscribe check out one of those great
videos right over there this been Max
and I'll see you in the next
[Music]
one